Je vais t'expliquer une balle qui tourne, sauf que ce n'est pas une balle et qu'elle ne tourne pas. Aujourd'hui dans Qiskit en
classe, nous parlerons de cette propriété quantique appelée spin en examinant l'expérience qui en a trouvé la première preuve.
Bienvenue dans Qiskit en classe. Dans cette série, nous utiliserons Qiskit pour explorer des concepts fondamentaux couramment
abordés dans les cours liés à l'informatique quantique. Chaque vidéo est accompagnée d'un module interactif
dont le lien se trouve dans la description ci-dessous, alors n'hésite pas à y jeter un œil. Aujourd'hui, nous parlons de l'expérience de Stern-Gerlach
de 1922. C'est l'une des plus célèbres de l'histoire de la théorie quantique car elle démontre si clairement comment le
spin quantique fonctionne. Mais ce n'est pas ce que Stern et Gerlach avaient l'intention de montrer. L'expérience a été conçue pour tester un nouveau modèle quantique
de l'atome appelé le modèle de Bohr, nommé d'après Niels Bohr qui l'a proposé en 1913. Dans ce modèle, les électrons tournaient autour
du noyau sur des orbitales discrètes et pouvaient transiter entre ces orbitales en absorbant ou en émettant
des photons. Chaque orbitale avait un moment cinétique quantifié qui était un multiple entier d'une minuscule constante fondamentale
appelée h barre. Dans les années 1910 et au début des années 20, la mécanique quantique était toute nouvelle, si nouvelle
qu'on ne l'appelait même pas encore mécanique quantique. Donc tout le monde n'était pas convaincu par le modèle de Bohr. Un physicien
nommé Otto Stern le détestait. Il qualifiait le modèle de « non-sens » et est même allé jusqu'à menacer de quitter la physique si Bohr avait
raison. Stern était tellement déterminé à prouver que le modèle était faux qu'il a trouvé un moyen ingénieux de le tester et
a recruté Walther Gerlach pour l'aider à concevoir et réaliser l'expérience. Il s'avère qu'il n'a pas prouvé que Bohr avait tort ; il a
fini par se prouver lui-même dans l'erreur. Leur expérience était si simple et les résultats si frappants qu'elle a pratiquement réglé le
débat : la mécanique quantique règne à l'échelle atomique. Ils ne s'en sont pas rendu compte à l'époque,
mais l'expérience de Stern et Gerlach a aussi trouvé des preuves concluantes du spin intrinsèque de l'électron, qui était une
nouvelle propriété fondamentale de la nature, essentielle pour expliquer le magnétisme, la supraconductivité et une grande partie de la
chimie. Aujourd'hui, je vais te guider à travers le fonctionnement de l'expérience de Stern-Gerlach, ce que nous nous attendrions classiquement à voir
lors de l'expérience, et ce que Stern et Gerlach ont finalement trouvé. Ensuite, je te montrerai comment tu peux réaliser ta propre expérience
de type Stern-Gerlach avec Qiskit et un ordinateur quantique IBM. L'idée de base de l'expérience de
Stern-Gerlach était de trouver un moyen de déterminer si le moment cinétique d'un électron dans un atome était quantifié comme
Bohr le prédisait, ou non, comme Stern s'y attendait. Ils ont utilisé le fait que le moment cinétique de l'électron causerait aussi un
petit champ magnétique autour de chaque atome. Tu peux donc les imaginer comme de minuscules aimants
en barre. L'expérience ressemblait à ceci : il y avait un four plein d'atomes
d'argent et un champ magnétique avec les pôles nord et sud
ici. Le champ était plus fort en haut et plus faible en bas, ce qui produisait un gradient pointant vers le haut.
Enfin, il y avait un écran. Dans l'expérience, le four chauffait les atomes d'argent jusqu'à ce qu'ils s'évaporent, puis
ils sortaient du four avec l'orientation du petit aimant en barre de chaque atome complètement aléatoire. Ensuite, les atomes
passaient à travers le champ magnétique. Les atomes étaient poussés vers le haut ou vers le bas avec une force qui dépendait de la direction
du pôle nord de chaque atome par rapport au gradient du champ. Ensuite, les atomes frappaient l'écran. Stern et Gerlach pouvaient regarder
où les atomes frappaient l'écran pour en apprendre sur le moment cinétique des électrons. Stern s'attendait à ce que les atomes
dans l'expérience se comportent comme je les ai décrits jusqu'ici, comme de minuscules petits aimants en barre obéissant aux
règles de la physique classique. Classiquement, ces petits aimants atomiques pouvaient être orientés dans n'importe quelle direction aléatoire, donc en
traversant le champ magnétique, ils pouvaient subir une gamme de forces différentes les poussant vers le haut ou vers le bas selon ces orientations. Un aimant
pointant dans la même direction que le gradient subirait une grande force vers le haut ; dans la direction opposée, il
subirait une grande force vers le bas ; et s'il était quelque part entre les deux, ce serait une force plus faible. Si l'aimant de l'atome pointait
perpendiculairement au gradient, alors il ne subirait aucune force et continuerait tout droit. À cause de cette
gamme de forces possibles, les atomes devraient tous frapper l'écran à différents points verticaux. Le motif qu'ils feraient
sur l'écran ressemblerait à quelque chose comme ceci. Mais ce n'est pas tout ce que Stern et
Gerlach ont vu. Au lieu de cela, ils ont vu deux taches d'atomes entièrement séparées sur l'écran, sans aucun atome au
centre. Ils n'avaient pas la bonne théorie à l'époque pour expliquer cela, mais nous savons maintenant qu'ils ont vu cela parce que
chaque électron possède une certaine quantité de moment cinétique intrinsèque sous forme de spin, qui ne peut prendre que l'une
de deux valeurs. Dans notre image d'aimant en barre, cela signifie qu'il n'y a que deux orientations permises des aimants atomiques. Nous appelons
ces deux orientations spin haut et spin bas. Un qubit dans un ordinateur quantique
ressemble à ce type de système de spin, et certains ordinateurs quantiques utilisent effectivement des qubits fabriqués à partir des états de spin
de l'électron. Nous pouvons donc réaliser notre propre expérience de Stern-Gerlach avec Qiskit et les qubits d'un ordinateur quantique IBM. Faisons
correspondre l'état spin haut de l'électron à l'état zéro du qubit et l'état spin bas à l'état un
du qubit. Quand les particules d'argent sortaient du four, elles avaient des moments magnétiques orientés aléatoirement. Nous
pouvons modéliser l'expérience de Stern-Gerlach en créant un simple circuit quantique avec un seul qubit commençant dans l'état zéro.
Ceci s'appelle un diagramme de circuit, où le fil du haut est le qubit et les opérations appliquées au qubit
apparaissent sous forme de boîtes sur le fil. Les boîtes RX et RZ sont des gates quantiques qui
effectuent une rotation de l'orientation magnétique de l'atome. Nous pouvons choisir des valeurs aléatoires de thêta et phi ici pour faire tourner le
qubit d'un montant aléatoire. Cela imite le four qui éjecte les atomes avec des orientations de spin aléatoires. La boîte grise est
notre mesure. Elle nous dit si le qubit est dans l'état zéro ou un, et envoie cette mesure à un bit classique, la
double ligne étiquetée C. Cette partie est équivalente à mesurer si l'atome est en spin haut ou spin bas en regardant
quelle tache il touche sur l'écran. Nous pouvons utiliser une primitive Qiskit appelée sampler pour exécuter l'expérience plusieurs fois, chacune avec
des valeurs aléatoires différentes pour thêta et phi. Après 100 échantillons, nous obtenons un histogramme de mesures qui ressemble à ceci : environ
50 % du temps, le qubit est mesuré à zéro et 50 % du temps, il est dans l'état 1. C'est le même résultat que Stern
et Gerlach ont observé : c'est toujours soit spin haut, soit spin bas, mais jamais entre les deux. À ce stade, tu te dis peut-être : eh bien,
évidemment que nous avons obtenu deux résultats discrets, nous avons réalisé l'expérience sur un ordinateur quantique numérique qui ne renvoie jamais que
zéro ou un. Et c'est vrai, mais garde à l'esprit que la raison même pour laquelle les ordinateurs quantiques renvoient des résultats binaires, en fait
pourquoi l'informatique quantique fonctionne, c'est exactement à cause de cette quantification du spin que Stern et Gerlach ont découverte en premier.
Les qubits des ordinateurs quantiques IBM ne sont pas basés sur les spins, mais beaucoup d'autres ordinateurs quantiques le sont. Donc réaliser une
expérience de Stern-Gerlach sur un ordinateur quantique nous permet de redécouvrir la quantification du spin.
Depuis 1922, d'innombrables extensions de l'expérience originale de Stern-Gerlach ont été réalisées. Ces extensions consistent à
envoyer le même faisceau d'atomes à travers plusieurs appareils de Stern-Gerlach pour voir comment les spins se comportent dans différents
scénarios. En voici un : envoyons les atomes à travers un appareil pour séparer le faisceau en deux, correspondant à un
faisceau spin haut et un faisceau spin bas, puis envoyons chacun de ces faisceaux à travers leurs propres appareils
séparés. Avec Qiskit, le circuit quantique correspondant à cette expérience est similaire au précédent, mais avec deux
mesures au lieu d'une. Ici, nous avons remplacé les rotations aléatoires qui imitaient l'effet du four par une
gate appelée Hadamard, car appliquer le Hadamard nous donne les mêmes probabilités de mesure que le four
nous donnait, mais c'est beaucoup plus simple à utiliser. Donc nous mesurons une fois, puis une deuxième fois, et
l'histogramme de mesures résultant de l'expérience ressemble à ceci, où les chaînes de bits sur l'axe X correspondent aux
résultats des deux mesures. Si le qubit a été mesuré à zéro les deux fois, cela correspond à la chaîne de bits 0 0, ou s'il
a été mesuré d'abord zéro puis un, cela correspond à 1 0, et ainsi de suite. Il semble que s'il a été mesuré spin haut dans
la première expérience, il sera spin haut dans la seconde. Pareil pour les atomes spin bas. Cela signifie que dans la première expérience,
nous avions une probabilité égale de mesurer haut ou bas, mais à la deuxième expérience, le résultat était déjà déterminé. Donc les
deux écrans à la fin de chacun des seconds appareils de Stern-Gerlach n'auraient chacun qu'une seule tache. Un écran aurait
tous les atomes spin haut et un écran aurait tous les atomes spin bas. Pour notre prochaine expérience,
commençons avec un faisceau d'atomes purement spin haut. Avec une véritable expérience physique de Stern-Gerlach, tu pourrais le faire en les envoyant
à travers un appareil de Stern-Gerlach et en bloquant le faisceau dévié vers le bas, de sorte que tous les atomes déviés vers le haut sont
spin haut. Maintenant, envoyons ce faisceau à travers un autre appareil de Stern-Gerlach, mais cette fois, tournons les aimants de 90° de sorte
que le gradient du champ dévie les atomes qui voyagent de cette façon vers la gauche ou vers la droite. Verrions-nous
une tache ou deux, ou quelque chose de complètement différent ? Pour cette expérience,
nous allons exécuter le circuit suivant sur Qiskit. Nous commencerons dans l'état zéro puisque notre faisceau d'atomes dans cette expérience est tout
spin haut. Ensuite, cette gate Hadamard échange les coordonnées X et Z de sorte qu'elle a l'effet de tourner
l'appareil de Stern-Gerlach. Donc maintenant nous mesurons la projection du spin à gauche ou à droite au lieu de haut ou bas. Ici, nous obtenons
l'histogramme de mesures qui ressemble à ceci. Nous pouvons voir que le spin selon X ne peut aussi prendre que deux valeurs,
que nous pouvons appeler spin gauche et spin droit. Donc cette expérience montre que si tu mesures la projection X d'un spin
qui a été précédemment mesuré comme spin haut selon Z, il sera spin gauche ou droit avec une probabilité égale. Comparons
cela une dernière fois à l'attente classique, juste pour vraiment mettre en évidence la différence. Classiquement, rappelle-toi que j'ai
dit que si le petit aimant en barre atomique pointait perpendiculairement au gradient du champ magnétique de l'appareil,
la force sur cet atome devrait être nulle. Il ne devrait pas être dévié vers le haut ou vers le bas. Dans ce cas, nous verrions une seule tache au
milieu de l'écran. Au lieu de cela, nous voyons deux taches. Donc la moitié des atomes ont spin gauche et la moitié spin droit, même
s'ils avaient été précédemment mesurés comme spin haut. Donc d'un point de vue de la mécanique quantique, bien qu'il puisse être tentant de
considérer spin haut comme un vecteur pointant vers le haut et spin bas comme un vecteur pointant vers le bas, ce n'est pas aussi simple que cela, comme nous pouvons le voir
avec la dernière expérience. Pour vraiment comprendre ce qui se passe ici, nous devrons approfondir les sujets de
la superposition quantique et de la mesure, ce qui sera le sujet d'une autre vidéo. Tout comme nous restons avec davantage de
questions sur le fonctionnement exact de la mécanique quantique, Stern et Gerlach aussi. Leur expérience n'a pas tout expliqué,
mais elle a grandement contribué à établir la mécanique quantique comme essentielle à la compréhension du monde
naturel. Ce fut l'une des expériences fondatrices les plus importantes en mécanique quantique, qui a à la fois prouvé la quantification
du moment cinétique et fourni des preuves d'une nouvelle propriété fondamentale de la nature appelée spin. Pour vraiment se confronter et
comprendre les règles du monde quantique, des physiciens comme Stern et Gerlach ont dû mettre la main à la pâte en concevant des
expériences, en faisant des prédictions et parfois en ayant tort. Il n'y a vraiment pas de substitut à essayer les choses soi-même.
Donc si tu veux tenter ta chance en réalisant de véritables expériences quantiques, rends-toi sur le module Stern-Gerlach
dont le lien se trouve dans la description. Merci d'avoir regardé et à la prochaine fois.